他以為每一波公高都會爆巨量
對不起 第一波公高會爆巨量
後面開始在拉高
就不會出現那麼多了
所以後面開始你要開始依次遞減
前面到10倍量 10倍多
後面可能8倍進10倍
接下來可能第三個高點
5 6倍就差不多了
所以為什麼會說
股價會有量價倍離
就這個原因
越到後面 就供應不足了嘛
了不了解 就供應不足了
這個道理很重要
所以一定要有這個
第一件事情
看到循環指標
加空訊號立刻撬到Tik徒
先找預估量
有沒有什麼
有沒有備量
有了備量之後
所以你要知道這個備量
什麼意思
它的外盤跟內盤
什麼叫外盤
用外盤敲進
懂了沒有
所有的股票跟所有的拍賣市場都一樣
這個我在上海看到的這個
農產極限低跟台北的這個
中央市場都一樣
所有的拍賣都是一樣
18塊58 6
18塊6 18塊7
18塊怎麼樣
價格一直往上走
外盤價
對 價格在往上堆
用外盤買就代表一件事
買進的意願怎麼樣
強
了不了解
用內盤一直成交往下跌
就是賣出的意願怎麼樣
賣出的那個急迫感
就是很強
這樣了不了解
所以你要看到
外盤的成交比重
我們現在親愛的眷商
我們現在親愛的這些
都已經幫我們設計好
外盤的成交比重
對不對
那要什麼叫做明顯的強
要61%以上
他就有可能當天
要拉出一根6%以上的長紅興奮
你不要再皺眉頭了
王姐姐 聽懂了沒有
我在教你數超票
你怎麼會皺眉頭呢
了不了解
61%以上
他就可以出現
當天要超過6%以上
像台灣跟大陸企業
漲停板是10%
如果是69%以上
親愛的
他很可能要漲停板
你現在懂得怎麼掛價了嗎
你們現在懂得怎麼掛價了嗎
楊姐姐就記得怎麼掛價了嗎
所以為什麼我給你的表格裡面
會有一個這樣子的設定
你一輸入是不告訴你一件事情
如果漲0.382是不21塊6
漲6.18%
0.6184的21塊9 22塊1
所以他看到沒有 他今天盤中高等了
22塊1是吧 22塊4
他盤中一定超過多少
他盤中外盤一定有一段時間超過60以上
所以你的掛價單你就掛著22塊1或者22塊
多少
3 為什麼
哇靠 學這麼快 我沒有招了
挂單不挂雙 懂了沒有
雙數你扎到 不見得成交到
你要找能夠成交到的